Layla never tried to change me the
majority of the other relationships that
I had was like you're here I'm here
let's meet in the middle so I always
felt like I had to be less than or a
different version of myself in order to
like make the relationship work so she
just kind of like oriented herself
around me and it worked amazingly well I
got to do what I want to do all day
which just worked did you feel like you
needed to compromise or bend a little
bit to fit Alex no honestly I think we
got really lucky because I was kind of
always the same way which is like I'm
not gonna be less of myself and less
ambitious and less career oriented for a
man so I actually really like the fact
that he wanted to work all the time
finally somebody that didn't tell me
like oh you need to go do your hair and
look pretty it was someone who's like
yeah you should learn how to do this
let's build a business I just love that
he believed in me so much